do no other apologies yes counselor
brain fine I hope everything goes well
for you the weather as we know is in
Clement the majority of staff will be
leaving at 4:00 but the office will
still be here with other members of the
staff here until 6:30 but if you all
behave yourselves
we may get away which would be rather
the minutes of the meeting secret
propose in a second for the share
opposer chair I've got a some comments
on the miniature for me always the facts
well one is a matter arising the second
point would be a matter arising which I
know isn't a separate agenda item so I
presume we take that under minutes is
that correct gives it an agenda item
from the last meeting it's well let me
tell my first point and then we go on
for matters arising so on four one one
here it's written up as though I raised
my three points which I accept and then
I disagree with the way that it's work
worded next because actually I looked at
the video last night and what actually
happened was you said you would take my
points on board and get back to me and
then I raised the question could you
give me a time frame to get back to me
and you said no we'll take off points on
board and get back to me but what I'm
very conscious of a that doesn't say it
here and B with respect show you haven't
got back to me so we are none the wiser
of the three points I raised last time
so I'd be grateful to know when you're
going to get back to me with the points
areas last time I'd like to think it'd
be before the end of this week or
matters arising on page six it is here
there is a comment in the minutes
towards the end when it says that it
reflects the comments raised by
residents who I represent and they were
told
they would get a response both witty
Allcock and the chairman of brags would
get a response a detailed response to
the planning issues they raised now they
have chased a number of times and still
have had no response so they they are
lying to me is they think the council is
treating them with a contempt what I
would like is confirmation about when
they will actually get a response so if
you could deal with those two points I'd
be most grateful whether we can give an
affirmative answer today is I believe
myself uncertain but a disciplined I
would have always introduced had I not
had the information I was seeking I
would have raised that need before the
occasion which were facing today it is a
bit unfortunate to have it presented at
the meeting I would have hoped you would
have asked for an answer beforehand all
I can promise now is that the two issues
you have raised will be addressed and we
will write to you within the next two
weeks which I think there's a reasonable
period of time can we take any other
points from the minutes of the last
meeting no fine announcements yeah can I
have a proposer under seconder for the
minutes sorry I ever proposed a
councillor Adams second death thank you
very much we now come on to
announcements I've got a few actually I
was asked to open the symposium of the
British scientific glassblowers
Association a couple of months ago one
of the arrangements they have is an
auction of their members wares and
whatever is raised is passed on to me
for whatever good cause I believe
appropriate on this occasion I decided
to split the 500 pounds between the
district's amateur boxing Academy and
the Stratford girls Football Club
I know that they have appreciated it
because there are certainly needing
equipment of various types we had the
Chairman's lunch week past Sunday which
was held at the RAC it was I believe a
very satisfactory event and I do thank
those who came not just from here but
from many other quarters as well a of a
member of the staff who organized some
superb musical and recital interlude now
I know of another which doesn't involve
me but apparently ulster have had some
remarkable achievement and appearing at
a place which was known for cricket I
think but as councillor getters is a lot
better versed in this matter than me I
will call upon him to give us a brief
description of what it is well thank you
chairman unexpected as it were yes
counselor Payne and myself had the
pleasure on the 29th of November of
representing ultra Town Council in
relation to an area of land which is in
within the ownership of the town council
and the District Council you may have
heard me talk regularly about the Green
River corridor in Austin which is an
area of green open space which the town
the community has been registering and
looking after for the benefit of the
well that Eric and I were called to
attend laws and we sat with three or
four hundred other people the great and
the good and listen to some magnificent
awards being given to people when we
came to the the most significant award
which related to partnership work I kind
of said to Eric earlier on of course
these awards always go to a greater
metropolitan areas they tend to follow
where the money's with the respect
however on this particular occasion but
it gots the relevant part in the
proceedings they turned out the dollar
store town
council had in fact won the award for
registering for areas with the national
playing field association the fields of
trust of the last for seven years two
conventional ones a nature reserve a
heritage site a a rec route manage
recreational area and lastly for next
year a centenary building trust which
will be to commemorate those that lost
their lives at the conclusion of the
Great War so it was a it was a Norman
surprise to us both that everything
dodged me I dropped my telephone which I
was trying to photograph the event at
the time and we we received the most
prestigious award in relation to the
local government working in partnership
with the plain national fields and Trust
a national playing fields association so
that's my report we had a great day and
a great TV evening and we came away with
the silverware and also the head of maid
service afterwards to give their
announcements leader of the council yes
chairman which is just one announcement
to inform the council that our
relationships with people in the city of
Fujian China have effectively taken
another positive step only last week I
attended and greeted some people in
London very difficult to get there
because somebody also had an opportunity
to threaten terrorist actions on Downing
Street and we were attending and he went
to the hotel just off Whitehall which
was somewhat difficult to get here
because the police had completely
reorganized all the traffic in that part
of London however we duly got there and
I addressed another issue up to now our
our it relationships between Fuji and
Stratford have been limited to dramatic
celebrations the fact that they have a
literary giant which was a contemporary
of will
Shakespeare but we do involve ourselves
with various activities and this one was
relatively low-key by comparison but I
had invited to Britain some people from
the the education side of things and
they are looking to extend our
activities into joint research work
which we have a lot of local interest in
and indeed performances and
interestingly enough I was asked because
the Chinese tend to have a different
architectural style to us
I was asked and this was completely off
the cuff I was not expecting it
have you got a sign in Stratford where
we could erect a pagoda now I'll just
leave that thought with you I just leave
that thought with you so if one suddenly
appears in the next few months you'll
know we found one but however thank you
chairman Thank You chairman just one an
announcement for me everybody will
notice that you've got one of these very
nice cards with pictures of the chairman
the first stratford-upon-avon Victorian
Christmas market took place at the
weekend Friday Saturday and Sunday
Sunday unfortunate was canceled due to
inclement weather but the feedback that
we've had particularly around Saturday
was a massive success and some of the
information that's been fed back to us
from the Business Improvement Districts
is that retailers had something like a
57% increase in trade on a Saturday so
we're hoping that that will be the start
of something that we can repeat year on
yeah thank you
think about the retailer's increase in
retail activity normally people say when
you have a market it detracts from the
opportunities of retailers it's nice to
see that is contradicted in
very good for our area
Thank You chair I suppose I'm not too
surprised by the detail in the answer
that I've received you've seen as well
it's a fairly generic reply but as a
supplement to that I would just ask how
as the Parish Council and members of the
public we can have the faith and the
confidence in planning committees making
decisions when members of that committee
express a need to leave before the
meeting is going to be finished
expresses a need to leave before
specific decisions are being discussed
and is understandably clearly anxious
when that particular discussion for that
particular decision goes on for a
considerable length of time it just
makes many of us worried that there is
insufficient detail and thought being
given to the decisions which are at such
significance and particularly when
directly related to neighborhood plans
many of which are now in place and one
at least is before you this afternoon to
make or whatever the expression is thank
you thank thank you mr. Gosling
obviously take on board what you what
you say Anton I mean I would expect that
all members of planning committees
understand the importance and relevance
of Neighborhood Development plans that
when they are considering applications
they give the appropriate weight to
those plans and they give the
appropriate weight and consideration to
the applications and clearly I'm not in
a position to to make any observation on
on the comments you've just made I think
in terms of trying to give you
additional confidence not just you but
other parish councils confidence that as
members of the planning committee and as
this council as a whole the question of
Neighborhood Development plans are taken
seriously I can personally assure you
that all members of this authority
particularly those whose wards do have
neighborhood development plans in place
quite vociferous in backing those plans
and looking to ensure that those plans
are given wait and do make a material
difference to the decisions we make as a
plan in authority I think that perhaps
one thought I have and and by their very
nature some of these things are generic
answers you know we have a training
program we've got to put things in place
but I'm looking towards towards my to
mr. Dolby over there I know it would
seem to me that we should extend the
invitation to offer to two members when
we've got indeed these sessions out to
parish councils so you can see for
yourselves the messages that have been
given and be part and parcel of
influencing the discussion and debate
there I think that would be a useful
exercise and would also you know help
build more understanding around the
thought process is that planning
committee members are earned to take
when they're when they're making their
decision so if mr. Dalby can add you had
parish councils to the to the invite
list and I can also give you the
insurance that around this room a number
of members are very very forceful in in
pushing the importance of Neighborhood
Development plans and they are very
definitely not an afterthought if you
will so but please keep us to our mettle
on that if you feel we're not then
please continue to challenge us okay all
right thank you mr Gosling for coming
and bringing up that point I presume it
means that the committee had come to its
decision was core it I think that's
something you know
unless you but I'm sure that would be
examined and dealt with if necessary
which I presume it isn't can we now move
on to agenda item 6 which is I've
overlooked the fact because he isn't
here mr. Ross one of my residents
they've had with residents association
that isn't here
the snow has trapped him in right gender
item six community governance review
harbouring bishops Akutan
unfortunately the chairman council ibaka
can't be here so therefore they report
cannot be followed up by her so we will
just have to acknowledge that fact and
assume that it is satisfactory
so in the absence of the chairman are
you happy to determine the
recommendations thank you
we now have an agenda 7 the report of
the independent remuneration panel it
may be appropriate to raise the point as
any member who might have a benefit
under the panel's opinions wish to make
any observation yes well chairman
apologies I didn't do it when you called
earlier but in view that my SRA is being
considered after discussions were mr.
Grafton I've decided to declare an
interest in this particular item and I'm
happy to leave the room whilst the
matter is discussed the make there may
be several if not more members in the
room who have a similar interest to
declare I don't think it's necessary for
individuals to actually declare provided
that the minutes acknowledge that all
those who will face possibly a change to
their allowance are making that
declaration
you've made a declaration so you council
say believes he ought to leave now the
report sets out sorry I beg your pardon
Oh council house sorry you have your
hand up you've retracted you quite happy
to remain where you are fine thank you
now the report sets out recommendations
of a light touch review of the council
ounces fear it was undertaken in October
this year number of recommendations
which I'm sure we've all read any
comments yes counselor chairman this is
describing the papers as a light touch
review yet it proposes an
across-the-board 14% increase in all
special responsibility allowances it's
worth noting chairman that over half the
conservative group claimed these extra
allowances it's also perhaps worth
noting that the staff continued to be
restricted in their pay possibly 2% this
year after the several years at 1% I
found it difficult to agree a 14 percent
rise for councillors in these
circumstances particularly chairman
since it's only one year before the next
council elections surely any major
increase such as there should be left
until the full four yearly review in
2019 German I have no trouble with the
other changes proposed in this paper and
there are a number of theta ones there
but I will be voting against the 14%
increase and since I'm the only non
conservative entitled for such an
allowance
I've already told mr. Weber that if this
is passed I will not be taking the
increase thank you do we have any other
I have noticed specifically that the 14%
I am chairman I've worked through the
figures every single one is slightly
over 14% do we have any other comment
yes yeah the point 21 where the panel
recommends that provision to repeal the
twelfth installment of basic loans it's
discontinued I am on member development
and I am aware that there are regularly
two or three members that do not achieve
I think we should still keep it and at
least keep it do you have a seconder for
that thank you yes do we have any
discussion on the recommend the proposal
the next take it to a vote all those in
favor
my apologies Jeremy but there are
several aspects to this I'm just
wondering a mr. Grafton is nodding I'm
just wondering if he should take the
point separately
yeah I I tend to think we should deal
with them separately are you happy for
that too yes so then we now therefore
revert to the proposal which has been
seconded and take a vote on it those in
favour the specific one which has been
made in relation to the discontinuance
of the basic amounts of the members
unsatisfied the training requirement
that is your proposal 21 of the reported
my proposal is to revisit this with the
new council in 2019 but that it should
continue so to be reexamining sir
chairman I do apologize shipment but
some members seem unclear about what's
being proposed the proposal newspaper is
that next year councilors will not lose
1/12 of their allowance if they do not
do the 12 hours training cakes proposal
councillor rods proposal is that should
be swung over to the following year and
that if people next year do not do 12
hours training they should lose 1/12 of
their allowances yes that's exactly how
I read it actually is that now clear to
everyone what has been proposed and has
been seconded my understanding is that
if a member in the financial year
does not fulfill the training
requirements then 1/12 of the allowance
or remuneration depending upon our we've
classified is withheld
let's gone on for a number of years
actually everyone happy with that has
that explained it
the panel has been aided by the chairman
of the panel who's Declan Hall who's a
very experienced academic in this field
and I'm sure that recommendation
wouldn't have been made unless they felt
that it was appropriate so that they're
proposing a discontinuance of that if if
you wish to continue with it then it's
it's down to really the agreement that
counselors of this council have as part
of their role as a counselor so in
endorsing if you want to endorse a
continuation of that policy and then
council has made its position clear and
individual counselors are expected then
to to adhere to that rule that's of any
help
yes I think it's worthwhile remember and
it has been in existence for some yes so
it has been formally agreed that the
meetings of this nature and has been
practiced for quite a period of time
Counsell Williams then council mr.
chairman on a similar issue the County
Council had this proposal and after
legal advice we were told it was not
enforceable well we can't comment about
that ours has been in existence for some
yes so it must have some degree of
credibility behind it
council Vaudrey was next similar point
and just forever for council ghitis was
saying I suppose the monitor offices
nobody answer the question he said he
was a senior academic running this thing
but if the counselor wrote you mr.
Grafton and said you know I don't want
you to take my money away what would
your response be
it's difficult to say without knowing
the specific facts of each injured
individual case I think it would need to
be looked at and I'm an individual case
really which I mean the fact in this
instance is that they haven't done 12
hours training I am aware actually that
members who have been dealt with it in
this way have appealed had a hearing on
the hearing has gone against them so
there is a practice factor there within
the authority which confirms it is a
policy which has been there for some
time
any other questions councillor Crump no
no he's it's all right counselor Carroll
you're next mr. Jim the paragraph 20 in
the report doesn't give a great amount
of detail as to why the proposal is
being made to remove this clawback I
just wonder how often it has been used
over the past few years if it has been
used very very sparingly then perhaps it
is a sledgehammer to crack a nut if it
has been used on a consistent basis then
there may be a logic in keeping it does
it work historically in this council I
think council sir will is well equipped
to answer that question Thank You
chairman with regards to council it
cattle the system does actually work as
much as we've had to or maximum three
people each year have had to come
forward for us to understand whether
they should be allowed to keep the 112
or not if we look historically with
regards to what it's done for member
training in the days when we had a
larger council we were lucky to get five
or six people training sessions we're
now in a situation whereby we get 14 to
16 yes it's been done by cards and stick
of the use of this one
well and yes it's also being done by
getting the right type of courses for
the council's that they request from
that person with their personal
development plans as regards to the
future if this 112 we lose it and we
don't no longer have that carrot and
stick it is hopeful that a we do not
lose the impetus that we've got from
members attending training and it's so
that the independent renumeration panel
it's a later date do come back soon if
we need to do something to help you
whether it's giving you an enhancement
on top of the the basic amount I do not
know but I am quite concerned about how
effective it will be initially in the
training that councillors want Thank You
counsel counsel the bars Thank You mr.
chairman we have to do training to be a
llama plumbing I don't see any reason
why we shouldn't do matted training to
be a counselor keep it as it is
Thank You councillor bonds no more
contributions can we now move to a vote
by way of show hands those in favor of
the amendment submitted by two cancer's
please show your opinion by raising your
hand
the recommendation which is that sorry
the recommendation by the remuneration
panel is that those who do not attend
the required number of training courses
has a penalty of losing 1/12 of their
allowance the recommendation here is
that that should be abolished but the
counselors have proposed and seconded
that recommendation is not accepted is
that fine yeah now can we move to the
vote again are you quite happy with that
campus you understand what it is the
recommendation from the remuneration
panel in this regard is not accepted all
happy with that can we now go back to
voting by a show of hands
those against right abstentions No so
the amendment has been carried by
nineteen votes to eight and we now move
on from that aspect any others items on
the remuneration panel's report take the
14% point separately
I would specialize are increased so you
want to formally propose that the 14%
increase is not implemented seconder yes
counselor Frederick do we want any
discussion on that particular issue yes
sir thank you just do things when was
the last time that there was an increase
in the allowances and also house the
Catholic the panel taken into account
they were reduction in the amount of the
number of members and the extra workload
on them has that been taken to account
as well crease well
my belief is that there has no been
apart from 1% I think last year there
has been no increase in the allowances
which we are currently enjoying I
presume the panel take all of these
matters into account but they have
decided that we are sufficiently
well-off not to benefit from any further
remuneration or allowance increase
council of Audrey was first clarify if
the monetary officer is happy that
people who will be killing directly
benefiting from this are actually able
to vote if that's appropriate or not or
should they be excluded from this
particular
amendment has been put yes I'm happy to
advise it's it's one of those situations
where there are so many members that are
affected by it that the debate would be
stifled I don't think that the the
benefit is so direct that individual
counselors need to do more than declare
counselor scientists decided otherwise
as with counselor Mills yes counselor
Rolf was first yeah I want to make a
point here the staff here at the council
over the last two three four years have
taken on a lot more responsibility just
like we as counselors have with the
reduction in Granberry counselors they
but the staff haven't had a 14% increase
they get a statutory one or two percent
increase I really do think we don't
think about the effect of council taking
this huge pay increase against what the
staff in this building will be getting I
really do think you should seriously
consider this well have no doubt members
will and but of course do remember
proportionality is an enormous
difference between members and full-time
employed staff counsel get us your next
Thank You chairman our I guess my
concern is how this would appear to the
community that we represent who in
effect pay our allowances so I am
concerned about it I think that's my
community you may well view the fact
that I work extremely hard for them as a
lot of my part colleagues do throughout
this room here and whereas we note that
obviously that the cabinet members and
the leader themselves work very hard to
I don't think they probably work any
harder by purporting than we do and I
wonder why it is is this
you know 14% is being offered to the
upper tier and nothing is being offered
to our slowly councilors I mean I think
my community would see it strange would
ask a question why it is that I haven't
been recognized as being worthy of a 14%
increase to replicate that being
provided by everybody else I think it's
a question I do recall councilor gages a
few few years ago I think you did make
representations to the remuneration
panel and you did say you're cleaner has
paid a greater hourly rate than
councilor which I thought was a very
good comparison action I could just come
back on that chairman I could tell that
I was wasting my time at that particular
event when towards the end of my
interview the chairman of the panel got
up walked across to the to the clothes
rack removed his hat and coat and made
it clear that the interview had been
come to a conclusion as far as he was
concerned now counselor Trump Thank You
mr. chairman I'm just concerned about my
podcast the role I work in local
government and if staff do work extra
hours they normally depending on the
grade you'll get paid overtime or if
they take on extra responsibilities of a
higher level they will get if requested
if they request an honorarium so there
is potential for staff to get additional
rewards for extra work or work at the
higher level so I think we just need to
make sure we have got our facts rights
before we start comparing with staff and
members but saying that oh I tend to
agree with the councilor ghitis that you
know why why are the upper echelon of
our political elite where the worth 40%
more than us back benches and people
were vice-chair of planning committee
Thank You councillor Crump yes counselor
forecheck
I think it just gives the wrong it sends
the wrong message
in times of repeat things are really
quite tough for not just council staff
here but people across this district
when they're finding things really very
difficult so so for that reason thank
you any other cancer no can we just
reflect sorry cancel role for now but
were you wanting to reaffirm your
proposal so that we can then deal well
it was actually Peter Moses proposal
seconded by Frank at strategy but I
would like to ask for a recorded vote
please thank you I would just like you
to restate that yeah but of course it's
canceled more some council fragile II so
pencil Moore's can you restate the
proposal so that we're absolutely
certain
I thought it exceptionally well chairman
but basically the 14% increase in
special responsibilities allowance
recommended by the panel is not
implemented council for actually do you
think that and we want to go to a
recorded vote
um yes we do counselor fractionation a
secondary so we can now proceed to the
recorded vote and this is for the
amendment okay Thank You chairman I'll
be calling each member of the council
eight and if you can advise whether you
are for abstaining or against councilor
acting simple counselor kettle
councillor Adams councillor Barnes
councillor brain councillor Bromwich
councillor Cargill councillor Crump
councillor fielding councillor Voytek
councillor fragile a counselor get us
cancel the grey Council Harris
councillor Jefferson councillor Lawton
councillor Mills councillor Moss
councillor organ councillor Perry
councillor pain councillor Pemberton
councillor Richards councillor Rolf
councillor farewell counselor Vaudrey
counselor Williams and counselor rights
thank you
those who abstain really there's a null
vote so so members we have as you
probably know we have 16 for non against
and 12 abstentions so there's no
academic debate between four and abstain
the proposal he has been carried any
other issue on the report of the
independent remuneration panel no fine
thank you for their worthwhile
discussion on two particular issues
which are of importance to us re so
we're voting you've covered the 14 and
what have you they covered but there are
other ancillary items you're happy to
carry those yeah all right fine
the general report apart from those two
items you're all happy that that be
carried yes agreed
thank you and therein yes so we've
carried that fine right cabinet of the
30th of October councillor st. as lead
of the council to introduce agenda items
8 & 9
number 8 is the site allocation plan
point of order
we actually voted on the rest of the
renumeration yes we have yeah there was
a verbal agree on that assumption that
there was no objection to it yes I did
two or three
I haven't actually voted on the rest of
the recommendation but can I assume
you're happy to follow the rest of the
recommendation no right now members
we've carried it do we want to come
can we come back Oh God yeah what is
your particular yeah your particular
issue on any other increases for anyone
else a big one
any other increases any other increases
in allowances no of course not that's in
the report the the recommendations were
very limited so we're quite happy we're
now accepting the report no one else
wants to write yet fine any more greets
can we have a few more degrees yeah fine
good thank you
now we come to what I've mentioned just
a couple of seconds ago the leader to
introduce agenda item 8 and indeed the
reason that they will be value today
unless you have an issue is that the
site allocations or the built-up area of
boundaries which is part of the site
allocations report which will be brought
before you in the fullness of time is
that for each of the LS B's there has
been a built-up area boundary defined
and approved and the purpose of item 8
is to get full council to endorse that
decision and therefore give some weight
when planning applications are dealt
with in planning committees because as
you must realize some applications will
be within the built up area boundary and
some will be outside it and there may
well be a different approach in both the
officers
recommendation and the committee's views
as to the position of the particular
development site so this is this is
important okay at the moment we're not
asking you to adopt them but we are
asking you to confirm the proposals and
they will go in to further documentation
that you will be asked to adopt earlier
next year if you read the report you'll
discover that there was a fair amount of
debate about these earlier in the year
this year because the boundaries were
drawn up and brought up before a body an
august body called the leaders policy
advisory group and they decided that
perhaps parish councils should have a
say and indeed many parish councils
chose to express views and many of those
views have been incorporated into
amendments now this is solely the LSPs
the local service religious not the main
rural centres the main rural centers in
the main have got another arrangement or
they had built up area boundaries
defined in the core strategy or they've
done it in a neighborhood plan but so
consequently this is only part of the
whole issue across the district as a
whole however in the cabinet papers ah a
whole list of plans and maps each with a
nice big black round around at the edge
now the built-up area boundaries are so
defined they don't leave a lot of space
for development within them there was a
proposal from one parish that the
built-up area boundary was moved back so
it could propose an area in the revised
boundary for development what would
actually happen in that development was
approvable it would be proposed and
moved to be granted out
the built-up area boundary and then
perhaps the built-up area boundary might
be moved around it as in when so it's a
case of carts and horses which comes
first and that's the principle
so these boundaries are quite tight on
the developed areas okay and they
therefore put as open countryside issues
in areas around it as I say a moment ago
this doesn't preclude development but it
does actually put a framework in for
recognizing the fact that built-up area
boundaries are important and they do
recognize the extent to which
development should be straightforward
with in the local service religious
bearing in mind that one of the problems
that I get is what happens when the
numbers of developments are proved in LS
B's in total exceed the limit put on us
by peat through the planning inspector
so what I'm doing chairman this
afternoon without any more ado is I'm
asking you to approve or receive and
endorse as appropriate these built up
area boundaries in the cabinet papers
and that will give them some weight to
be expressed in the assessment of
planning applications within those areas
yeah I just need clarification on
something I represent two of the
villages in the the list that are not
being included in the consultation
absolute to Newton so what what you said
earlier was that if we agree this those
with built-up area boundaries approved
will carry more weight when it comes to
a planning application does that mean
that during Tanana
for instance because it's part of the
stratford-upon-avon neighborly plan will
not carry as much weight and if so is
that fair can you just help me out here
because I'm slightly confused
I think mr. chairman the best way of
describing it that Elvis said in telling
Tyndall Ford get their restrictions if
you like approved in a different way
right so in other words the
stratford-upon-avon neighborhood plan
which is at an advanced stage we don't
actually have it yet ready for dealing
with its final stages of independent
review assessment by the council and
then ultimately the referendum but it is
expected that the neighbourhood plan
will effectively define restrictions on
building on the green fields around both
of those villages they are important
villages and I will concede that point
well the weight will be greater when the
stratford-upon-avon neighborhood plan
gets his approval but on the other hand
we're not giving anything any weight by
giving you a list that doesn't include
those two villages that sounds a bit
cockeyed probably I know I can tell from
the look on your face yeah I'm trying to
help you out and I might be confusing
you even more which is purely
unintentional I can assure you I think
you'll find if you get an application in
either Alveston or tootington
there will be other factors that have a
similar effect to having a built-up area
boundary around whatever you know and as
I've already said and I was looking
straight at councillor Mills and mr.
Gosselin over this because I'm aware the
Contin have an approved neighbourhood
plan they don't have a built-up area
boundary
list that's before us this afternoon but
they do have stipulations which govern
where they can or cannot build we do
have a problem in that one of those has
got rather more developments in it than
than the parish at one time anticipated
but effectively that control was still
there so basically you know we're in a
state of limbo in fact because I'm not
asking you to approve these as gospel
but I'm asking you to give him some
weight such that in in an area I'm
trying hard not to pick where I live
I'm conscious of other white pillars and
prizes flying around in my head because
there was a planning application pilots
and priors a few weeks ago where there
was a lot of argument about the
proximity of the development site to the
built-up area boundary okay and
therefore this wasn't in place therefore
couldn't be put in to help determine to
that application and but as I say I I'm
reasonably confident also as you will
know from applications in telling t'en
the one we didn't want was approved by
the inspector but virtually most of the
other applications that might join
kidding turn on to Locksley Road and
therefore part of Stratford have
effectively been turned down and that is
their status they won't get developed
and therefore there was enough
protection in the core strategy as you
stand to achieve that result any other
question yes
councillor Keppel vice chairman mr.
showen can't just fall further
clarification from something that
leaders said does this prevent planning
committees for mr. Sain to finishes mr.
Mill's
does this prevent the Planning Committee
approving an
outside this boundary if it meets other
planning criteria I think the simple
answer is No
any other question no well thank you the
leader for that okay we now deal with
safe garden policy for sorry a bigger
pond yeah yes sorry you have page 77 we
have got to endorse the recommendation
are you all happy to do that thank you
sorry about that outside
next item leader the safeguarding policy
is also in exactly the same is exactly
the same cabinet papers and to save on
paper piles we published it as a an
electronic attachment and everybody gets
a copy of the cabinet papers so if you
wish to refer to it that can come along
we are being asked to endorse a
countywide policy here there has been a
change in governance arrangements this
year and I'm now on the mailing list for
a pan Warwickshire safeguarding panel
I've been to a meeting yet but there's
one coming up shortly after Christmas
which is it my diary and I shall attend
in parallel with that approach by the
County Council there has been quite a
lengthy safeguarding policy for adults
for example they then puts it on here
the adults are experiencing or at risk
of abuse or neglect brackets vulnerable
adults now we have duties in local
government to make certain that our
decisions do not affect these people
adversely and indeed part of the
paperwork is an incident in ruled an
incident reportage policy and in the
commentary on how that might be
interpreted and handled but the
important thing is the paperwork before
us today that's in those cabinets papers
was effectively or has also between
being around the other four councils in
more action so we're being asked
effectively to endorse this to create a
Warwickshire wide solution to how we
might handle vulnerable adults and look
at the distinctions and the decisions
that we as a council and other councils
may well have to make so again I commend
this document to you on the grounds that
we would not be out of step with other
councils if we adopted it any questions
for the leader no we all happy to
endorse the recommendation on page 80 of
the agenda agreed thank you
now come on to agenda item four five
nine treasury management strategy
mid-year review counselor organ you're
going to introduce this topic thank you
any questions for cancer organs all
agreed with the recommendation Thank You
counselor
sorry minute eleven calendar of meetings
as you know counsel Barbara is not here
it stretches beyond next year into 1990
I presume you're of all dire eyes that
you're all happy with the detail there
2019 yes yes never mind never mind never
mind comrades so you're all happy with
that thank you
it's agenda item yeah 12 now community
infrastructure levee adoption and that
will be introduced by councillor sinked
chairman this paper has been a long time
coming as it makes it quite clear we
have to put it through the same process
in the same procedures as we did to
adopt the core strategy and we all know
how long that took so we've had to have
on our community infrastructure there be
a process of going through what's called
an examination in public eeew IP
presided over by a member of the
planning inspector we then had to wait
for the planning inspector to actually
publish a report which is copied into
the cabinet papers for
I will double-check the date mr.
chairman so I've got it right it's in my
tile here somewhere 27th of November
you've got there before me yes so
effectively the work is is all there in
there there's quite a lot of papers and
supplements that go with it which
haven't been reproduced us afternoon
which is why again you're us if you
needed to refer to it to bring that
cabinet paperwork with you today right
I bought it not that I need to be
completely refreshed in here but I
needed to wave it around that you so
that you could recognize that the
officers in asking you to bring it were
effectively reporting a tangible
document community infrastructure levy
will alter the way that we actually
collect developer contributions towards
infrastructure currently these are done
by 106 agreements one of six agreements
are not going to disappear there will
still be 106 agreements for affordable
housing so those of you that sit on
planning committees and many others who
attend them will be familiar with the
kind of recommendation that those
committees get they get that you are
recommending to grant approval to this
particular application subject to and
the subject to is usually a satisfactory
106 obligation and therefore that is a
legal document which are prepared
individually on a case-by-case basis on
an application by application basis
agreed by us the County Council and
other interested parties not
withstanding the developer now that
effectively will still be there and
certain highways issues might still be
dealt with and other forms of
nation but most of the stuff that those
developer contributions contribute to
things like education community
facilities children's playgrounds open
space etc etc will come from a new levy
called the community infrastructure levy
well it will come if this council
approves the arrangements that we've set
in place and have been subject to public
examination plus the planning inspectors
report now then what will then happen is
quite interesting because the government
have decided that parish councils can
have their slice of this money so I
expect that when this is collected mr.
Buckland will feeling fairly will be
sort of fairly prompt in paying out to
the parish councils their dues and if
you've got a neighbourhood plan in place
you get more than if you don't it's
quite simple now what we have got in the
documentation is first of all a table of
what we can charge and the big sticking
point was the new settlements like GLH
and thereby well fortunately we were a
fairly advanced stage in developing 106
agreement and that has meant that the
inspector has said you can't charge
community infrastructure levy for either
of those two developments a bit bizarre
I see one or two strange faces looking
at me as I say that but that is what the
inspector has said therefore in our
policy and our charging policy that is
exactly what we are going to have to do
we don't have any choice we have to
follow the inspectors advice right so
what have we done in here is we
published some additional documentation
like a user guide an exceptions policy
right and a set of rules and regulations
and what's important is what's called a
regulation one two three lists this is a
statement of what we can effectively
spend the community infrastructure there
beyond because unlike the 106 agreement
where you actually develop proposals
like so much money for a new school or
so much money for a new road or so much
money for some more traffic lights in
Birmingham Road remember those days
right I don't particularly wish to but
that we we have to be reminded of it
this pool of money will be handled in a
very different way and more papers will
come to you on that the important thing
is we have looked at the proposals we've
looked at the examiner's report
it has been decided informally that the
first of February would be an
appropriate date to switch over onto the
new system of collecting developer
contributions and that's one of the
important decisions to make today now in
this context chairman there is
effectively a request mr. Grafton's
reminded me of which we didn't take
account of when we were dealing with as
a cabinet and you should have had a
single sheet of paper which says
community infrastructure levy adoption
and there is within that paperwork and
exceptions report or an exceptions
policy now the exceptions that come up
before committees when they come in the
same way as a decision is now to there
be 106 agreements right and if you look
at it the amendment which I'm going to
propose here and now it is effectively
quite straightforward a letter will be
sent to the applicant setting out the
council's decision whether
ECR that's exceptions whatever including
a brief explanation there is no right of
appeal but a review could be requested
though though it suggests if we take
that out and replace it by the relevant
Planning Committee will determine each
application there is no right to an
internal appeal or review in other words
if it is considered expedient to grant
one of the exceptions to relieve
developers of community infrastructure
levy that's decision will be made by the
Planning Committee when an application
is granted it's as simple as that
so I'm asking Council if they will
approve that amendment to the exemptions
policy so I think I've said enough mr.
chairman
so all in all I do want the three
recommendations to council to be
approved today but the charging schedule
including the regulation one to the
three lists that I've referred to is
adopted the exceptions policy be adopted
that's as amended and the effective date
for the introduction will be the first
often February Thank You chairman
council moss I think you were the first
thank you
I wish the point on developer
contributions if you feel this is too
far adrift from the agenda item please
tell me and I'll raise it and questions
to the leader later but it is obliquely
connected with it chairman the leader
and members will be aware I'm quite sure
that a large number of developers and
they using viability reports to justify
a reduction in the provision of
affordable housing and sometimes
chairman that's even after initially
agreeing to the 35% affordable housing
at the time planning permission is
granted coming in later with a variation
for a reduction in that shim and I'm
sure the leader is also aware there are
a number of counts
are now using clawback agreements with a
post audit of the viability study to
ensure that any excess profits over and
above those agreed in the viability
study are shared between the developer
and the council so chimin would cancel
saying please
urgently consider the introduction of
clawback clauses by this council thank
you I'm succinct yes chairman I think is
a very sensible suggestion it is a
little bit of beam as you suggest but
I'm happy to deal with it now the issue
as far as viability is concerned is that
we've recently responded to a white
paper from government called putting
houses in the right for the right number
of houses in the right places and it
asked questions on these clawback
agreements and I wasn't too charitable
to the development industry and the way
I responded to them because I believe
when they get Planning Commission and
agree to 35% affordable housing they
take a commercial risk right that's it
and none of this rubbish that we get
from the government you've got to
maintain profitability of levy of about
18 percent I can't agree with that I
think we just been too soft and the
development industry must get his mind
made up from day one
so I'm Easter and I I actually met the
Planning Minister and the chairman of
the Select Committee on CIL another
event in London recently and I
understand these points are being taken
seriously the viability will be less
straightforward to the development
industry than it's been right away but I
agree that that we ought to make certain
that developers contribute their fair
share because if they don't we've got a
hound English and we're going to come
across a time where everything is going
to accumulate and then I although it was
leader at the time because it might be a
long way off oh they're going to get
confronted with
all these people on the waiting list we
can't afford to let it slip that 35% is
there for a purpose and if one developer
doesn't want to develop land of that
well fine developer bleed to do it
instead any other question counselor mr.
Chanin as one of three Ward members who
cover the area of grading life on Heath
I know at least one of my parishes will
be disappointed to find that they won't
be able to draw down any funds from mr.
Buckland on a CIL levy on Gaiden on my
new settlement is there any provision
that the inspector might have considered
that would enable villagers and I'm sure
the place would be the same in Randall
Marston to enable those villagers who
have been precluded from the seal the
sill regime to receive any additional
funds to compensate them for the
devastating impact of two and a half or
three thousand houses in their immediate
neighbor neighborhood I think the
straightforward answer the counselor
kettles question is we are required to
comply with the law and if the law
places restrictions on community
infrastructure levy I we don't collect
it
we've got no funds to pay council parish
councils that might feel aggrieved by
that and therefore we are following all
the legal processes that we have been
required to and I'm bringing you a play
for the day which is compliant with all
those like everything else when the core
strategy was approved I had to stand
here and say the planning inspector has
declared this compliant with legislation
and I could say exactly the same thing
today and I'm not aware of any
exceptions which could redress parishes
they will get the infrastructure
but they won't necessarily get a
proportion of it to spend in their own
way like other parishes will any other
question members so red now we have got
also in the report an issue about the
lovely exemption levy exemptions policy
is that something you want to cover
counsel st. all I'm presenting the
exemptions policy for approval chairman
and I've requested an amendment to it or
proposed an amendment to it which has
been drafted for me by mr. Grafton so
again it's legally compliant and
appropriate so effectively I have
nothing else to say in the matter
chairman any questions members so we've
got the recommendations on page 94 are
you all in agreement with
recommendations four five and six as a
minute sorry as amended all in agreement
thank you next item 13 is the Welford on
Aven Neighborhood Development Plan and
you are earning your money
counselors centers ever well I've not
been informed whether councilors
approved it
so consequently these
well for our a run successful
Neighborhood Development Plan referendum
version you might not have all got a
color copy of this perhaps I'm a little
bit privileged but indeed it has been
before its referendum so and a suitable
number the number escapes me so I can't
tell you exactly who it was so how many
was but enough people I'm sure that
councillor Barnes could tell me how tell
me I've got it wrong if I got it wrong
so I'm not going to give you a figure
more than 50% of the voters of
considerably more than 50% of the voters
of Welford on Aven at a public
referendum voted to approve the
referendum version so-called because
there were other versions that were
developed on the way and were amended
such that the referendum version right
mr. Buckland is waiving 869 at me you
know he eagerly looked on bye-bye mr.
Dalby who conducted the referendum a
26.0 AG 6.9 right very wrong yeah you'll
have to write more clearly David Reich a
book with all these figures so the
situation is that with that vast a
number say we have very little choice
but there's a council to adopt it but we
have the duty and the responsibility to
adopt it
so like the ones that have gone along
beforehand I'm going to put forward the
proposal that the document I've just
waved at you is effectively adopted from
today and therefore will be a material
consideration in planning applications
that fall within that parish thank you
cheering thank you I know council of
bonds wish to save something no we're
just here to support it mr. chairman we
didn't have speaking and carry on any
other comment so you're all happy to
support the recommendation one and two
on the welfare on Aven they agreed X
thank you can we now move on to
committee reports and we've got councils
to present their committee reports the
very first one is councillor Barker but
as we know she's unfortunately not here
that's audit and Standards Committee at
the 13th of November 2017 as a member
I'm happy to propose that is adopted you
all agree excellent over the improvement
committee councillor house Thank You mr.
chairman I'm pleased to announce that
the committee reports Committee for the
4th of October the 11th of October and
the 25th of October are completed and
are on the website for inspection and
just before I sit down I would like to
remind members that there is a training
session on scrutiny this Thursday at 5
o'clock in this room thank you thank you
and then also regulatory committee
councillor Lawton Thank You chair
members I just ask you to please note
the regulatory committee of the 29th of
September 2017 thank you you're all
happy to note that fine excellent
and now cabinet 1 2 3 only four meetings
councillor st. yes but for some very
important meetings two of which we've
referred to in some substance this
afternoon so they have been done for
notice of decision but I must draw
members attention and your attention
to a lesser I've had today from mr. Ross
Craig the chairman of the Greg trust now
he writes to me fairly frequently at the
moment mr. Greg when the cabinet papers
were announced that we were proposing to
serve notice on the Greg Center to
terminate the leisure agreement whether
them I think they sent a letter to me
every day they then came and spoke at
the cabinet meeting with yet a different
proposal to what they had put in their
letters and this highlights some of the
problems in this letter I've had today
which is addressed
all counselors so presumably others have
it as well and it does make statements
the council knows full well well the
charity is not able to transfer the
groups or in accordance with charity law
that's something that we could challenge
and I'm sure that mr. Grafton would
identify for me a number of grounds for
challenge of that statement but ever
since we've been dealing with them for
three years now three and a half years
we've been dealing with a great Center
into trying to get a solution for the
closure of the hall and the
deteriorating or the deteriorating
financial situations as we saw it of the
great trustees and we've been in
frequent conversation with them read
this you will assume that effectively
we've totally ignored them well I'm not
going to say any more about that other
than we did serve notice subject to
calling I'm not aware that it's been
called in but whatever the situation is
we propose to implement that decision
but it is in most minutes and I thought
that once again sadly we've had some
representation from the trustees which
really I don't a sort of view with any
particular weight we've taken our
decision based on circumstances legal
financial advice everything went into
the melting pot to deal with it and
countless attempts to engage with them
yet we seem to have got nowhere they say
we can't comply with what you want us to
do
well that's challengeable and I think
the council
continue to endorse that decision Thank
You councillor st. the next item is an
urgent report and it's for noting that
is two minutes three nine eight and five
fifty about property purchase all aware
of that and I now move on to agenda item
16 which are questions which have been
received
they've been circulated to the all on
separate reach now all members ask some
questions will have the opportunity to
ask one supplementary question
there's councillor for tech have any
supplementary question no but we just
take them in order actually question one
on fourth a yes question
- don't bear in mind that capsule which
uses absent sorry
yeah yes it is too full councillor
Richards okay yes obviously note I have
is that number to the can remember
responsible as councillor Rich's
supplemental it may not be able to the
arms of today but just following up how
much has been claimed within the the
budget for the local council tax
reduction scheme really it there hasn't
been enough claimed and I just wonder
whether residents that are are actually
able to claim this or aware of its
availability and perhaps council could
allocate some funds for greater
promotion of this game thank you
answer Richards nominated accident
obviously I can't speak on councillor
Ritchie's behalf this is his portfolio
portfolio and I will speak to him about
your question and we'll get response to
you directly right there were on
question three counsel Vaudrey do you
have a supplementary question no
supplement you do so counselor will
can't be called good again counsel
Vaudrey you have another question do you
have a supplementary no Oh counsel
payment and you've lost an opportunity
counselor five counselor Moore's do you
have a supplementary question for
counselor brain again counselor moss no
counselor frankly I just say thank you
for the answer I think it needs this
need to be slightly more specific I mean
our protocol as I understand it offers
some help to rough sleepers providing
the weather forecasts forecasts three
nights of Norton below and and below
freezing looking at my weather forecast
it's - 10:00 tonight - 1:00 tomorrow and
one on Wednesday which would mean that
protocol wouldn't be triggered so what
I'm really asking is actually can we
look at the Warwickshire district
district councils protocol which
actually involves warm light I know all
the difficulties and the fraught
difficulties here whether we've got
enough accommodation where the people
will accept that accommodation etc etc
and can I just say here I think our
officers working with people on the
street are doing a fantastic job and are
getting to as many vulnerable people as
they can and I fully support them but I
do think looking at this more lenient
protocol to offer help
would actually go some way to help
people who are in dire circumstances
I've spoken to two people on the way up
here who are who look as if there are
out from the night so thank you Thank
You counselor virtually entirely happy
to review our current protocol I
completely agree with you that our
officers do a fantastic job looking
after those that presenters homeless and
those that are rough sleepers I can tell
you that this morning the officers
confirmed to me that over the weekend
all rough sleepers in Stratford town
have been provided with a safe place to
stay and we have extended all bookings
with Ben brevis for the next week so
they are being looked after it is a high
focus for us and and counselor right you
can't ask supplementary because council
Richards isn't Ritchie's isn't here fine
can we now move on to 17 questions to
the leader two questions per member
maximum three minutes in total for each
counselor and only matters that are the
responsibility of this council 30
minutes in total its 532 it my watches
right council Vaudrey yes week 30 not
530 but that's a I have two questions
I'd like to ask if I may share the first
one on the minutes leader page six
towards the bottom there's a sentence in
the answer from councilor Pemberton that
says primary education is both specific
and falls within the board a category of
educational purposes can I ask what are
they within the realms of Education what
other things are specific and fall
within that broader category could I ask
why
neither the resident group nor I were
ever consulted about about such a change
and can I ask that you with me meet the
resident group and work out what we can
do to actually dig ourselves out of this
mess that unfortunately we found
ourselves in putting forward a primary
school
when in bishop term we have a primary
school already that's just been
massively extended and in the timeframe
of this is talking about this 106 is
never going to be fill and i'll sensibly
what we've ended up with is giving to
the developers a piece of land to build
new houses on so can we work out how we
can dig ourselves out of this metal
piece chairman taking the question
backwards I'm very sympathetic to the
dilemma we have here and trying to find
a solution because there is little doubt
in my mind that mistakes were made they
weren't made in this council they were
made elsewhere and might I also say that
with the comments I made on SIL that
under community infrastructure levy
paying for education we might have a
little bit more control in this council
and prevent this sort of situation
occurring again what actually happened I
believe was that the new school was put
in a 106 agreement at the same time as
the County Council were considering a
bid for funding for the existing primary
school in Bishop turn now the situation
is this yeah if land has been earmarked
for public use they should not actually
sort of fall back under the control of
the developers but I would need to take
some legal advice on this matter and
indeed I would effectively like to think
two things one is taking the former
party or question right as I said a
moment ago in future if we learn our
lessons from this unfortunate situation
we would effectively not run into that
risk again that the all new schools
would effectively be effectively
commissioned from self funding and we
would have a mechanism to take better
control of it but secondly if there is
and I think options might be limited I
would be perfectly happy to meet with
residents associations in his ward and
see whether we can find a solution
whereby if we can't use this land for
educational purposes these put back to
some other public use I need to hear
obviously what they have in mind before
I could give too much commitment to that
but in principle the answer your
question is yes supplementary for second
question Thank You Chet
leader last last call council I asked
you about progress on the transport
consultation review and I know
councillor Richard wasn't there last
time so it's a slightly fudged answer
can I ask since then is there any update
to that and if there is could I ask if
it is published before the next full
council meeting could it be something
that is put on the agenda
so we could actually have I think
there's so many people have views on it
it would be great if we could actually
have a sort of a wide scale debate with
all members on on the results of that
consultation process so that can be part
of the whole debate thank you yes last
week I attended a meeting with councilor
Pemberton and councilor thermal mr.
Buckland and mr. Webb and an equivalent
array of county council officers it had
taken a since about September to arrange
this meeting but indeed the transport
strategy was very much on our agenda
what has happened now is they've
actually given us advance copy of
something which we are told by the
leader of the County Council will be
published on the 15th of December which
is only a few days away there is issues
about it and you know basically I think
there was a resource issue at the county
council but equally well the
opportunities that we've had for seeking
funding to help towards its
implementation is important so I'm
anticipating something comes in the
public domain which will be I'm told by
mrs. seccomb
a joint district and county strategy
so I think we are seeing unless we can
get our act together very quickly that
what is put in place is a draft which we
can put through the policy evaluation
structures that we have within this
council but I hope there's a slight
caution in my arm sir but I hope it also
contains some good news Thank You
Council for tech you were Thanks
thank you disadvantaged children and
adults outcomes in wealthier areas of
the country
wealthy areas of the country according
to the social mobility commission fair
fair fair much worse and out of the 324
local authorities Stratford K 130 second
that's in an area of very high wealth
therefore if you're poor there are 130
one other local authorities where your
chances of social mobility are greater
I hope the leader will look clearly at
this report and direct council policy
and decisions towards social mobility of
our poorest residents to improve the
life chances so that this local
authority can be a much better place to
live I don't think mr. chairman that the
judgment on there is necessarily
directed just at this council right
there are a range of authorities that
are responsible for dealing with things
and we I can assure you will want to
play our part I thought when you spoke
you were going to leave me to make
another statement about Children's
Centres which I'm reluctant to do we
have got to use the facilities and we've
got to try and make them work bearing in
mind that the County Council was
empowered to make the decision that it
did make so consequently we have a
situation whereby I think I'm a little
restricted on what I can say today
for the simple reason but nobody wants
to see disadvantaged children suffering
at the expense of others around them and
I think this is the nub of your question
and there's a number of things that we
can do we can provide them with better
housing with better education facilities
with public realm facilities like play
areas opportunities to actually mix and
deal with an awful lot of other issues
as well of course in parallel with what
the County Council can do and indeed in
a conversation I have with mrs. second
she was very conscious of the fact that
perhaps some of the disadvantaged
children were missing out right at the
expense of some of the wealthier ones
that you refer to so consequently I
think it's on the tip of our tongue
we've got to play our part in a
multi-agency
solution did you say they've heard a
second question I do think you know then
we know that the Tory government didn't
do the black sick impact assessments
even though on the 30th October David
Davis said that the studies existed will
the leader insist on perhaps impact
assessments for Stratford district
particularly in farming tourism in the
service sectors we know EU citizens
coming to work in the NHS has fallen 94
percent and we're already low
unemployment the impacts on our farms
care homes restaurants hotels and
hospitals could be disastrous for the
Stratford district absolutely that could
take a cue from the EU itself who did
their own effective impact assessments
as long as we're as long ago as last
March thank you I think chairman we've
got to rely on the government coming
forward with quite a considerable amount
of evidence so your assessment that it's
finished and we haven't dealt with it I
can't share I think we
fine now as we go through various stages
of another year or more of brexit
negotiations that effectively the
evidence will come forward and I agree
with you in this area the hospitality
industry is important and if we did
start from European countries to help us
manage it then which so be I would be in
favor of making allowances for them if
we have issues of Agriculture you
mentioned as well again the agricultural
economy in this part of the world and
across Frankfurt District is vitally
important and indeed there's an aura of
pasture land given that cross to
livestock which is vital for our
national and local economy so all of
those must be protected but if you feel
that the evidence isn't there at the
moment I wouldn't give up hope on it
coming what I would say which is not in
your question but I have been involved
in it is that after brakes did a number
of powers will be transferred back to
Britain a number of ploughs where
perhaps European civil servants would
affect adjudicate on it and there is
some work going on through the Local
Government Association the LGA in which
I am involved whereby we are looking to
make certain that when those powers are
repatriated back to Britain they don't
sit in London with Whitehall civil
servants but the important issues like
maintenance of green spaces that council
gives us was very proudly talking about
at the beginning of this meeting those
sort of issues should not be dealt with
by London civil servants but should be
repatriated to local councils and
there's a lot of work going on in there
which I would do my best to influence to
make certain that we effectively have a
role in making certain that the local
economy of stratford-upon-avon district
is effectively enhanced
protected now Council of freshly you are
next thanks Jeff just referring to the
minutes I think of the last meeting item
5 may I ask if the recent planning
application for the 400 houses at Long
Marston if this is sufficient advance to
trigger this council to take some advice
now about possible compensation for
residents who might find themselves in a
blight situation particularly in
reference to thank you I'm well aware I
I think the issue there is we need the
planning application for the
south-western relief Road in I'm not
aware that we've got that at the moment
I'm not getting any reaction from mr.
week so yes I am
he's saying no right so we don't have it
okay therefore that is going to restrict
our ability to it to assess blight and
as I've said the boy I know how King you
probably are to make certain leaf blight
is due to certain household as it should
be paid but it will be a responsibility
of the developer and not not this
council so consequently consequently
planning applications as you know I
can't be expected to know the day-to-day
details of progress of them all but we
would endeavor to keep you advice on the
subject do you have a second question no
no no yes that's always shake your hands
in a negative manner councillor Mills
thank you Miss chairman Thank You leader
Kyneton had its neighbourhood plan
adopted last year with over 45% of the
residents in kiting voting and more than
90 percent of those in favor of it at
the first two sets about at the first
two tests of our plan applications were
granted against the wishes of the
residents in kind and contrary to the
Kyneton neighborhood development plans
policies these upsets are now set to
present that we now have an application
from another developer
wanting to build on the adjacent piece
of land next to the applications in
question when the developer was told by
Kyneton Parish Council that they will
object to the application because it was
contrary to the clinton neighborhood
development plan the developer said but
he couldn't see this a stumbling block
knowing how the previous applications
went last year just for our plan was
adopted an application was rejected for
90 homes and application was empty homes
of the was withdrawn due to that pending
kinds and Neighborhood Development Plan
as you were seen by the dead of
developer and inspector at the time to
carry considerable weight in light of
the recent planning decisions I have had
a number of concerned residents who
would have been affected by the 90 homes
emailing and calling me worried that the
developer will come back and reapply
because of these planning decisions
leader the kind of Neighborhood
Development Plan took over four years to
prepare and it's considered a very
thorough plan by our officers in light
of the planet decisions how do you see
or consider the importance of
neighborhood plans as the residents and
the kinds of neighborhood dependent plan
steering group throughout their four
years of working on the plant have been
pointless I'm Phil it is not worth the
paper is written on furthermore in view
of the government actively promoting
localism would you say that in this case
we the District Council had failed the
residents of kinds Thank You leader
chairman judging I think we have a very
unfortunate situation here as councillor
Mills knows before the neighborhood plan
was adopted I was fairly active at one
of two appeals in trying to constrain
development in coins and which could
easily conflict with what was then the
emerging neighborhood plan and I was
very pleased when it got such a positive
response from from the local electorate
however I wouldn't go so far I wouldn't
want us to
clewd today's proceedings with some
observation from the leader of the
council that this council has failed the
residents of clinton i understand your
feelings and i've had discussions with
mr. Gosling about this who's still sat
at the back of the room hearing this
part of the meeting and indeed spoke to
us on the similar topic at earlier on i
think we have got an issue to deal with
here if the public concern is low then
quickly we've got to act doubly
carefully right in any future planning
applications we must dispel the feeling
in developers that effectively that you
can just knock aside the principles that
are in neighborhood plans both for the
ones that are there already the newly
adopted one which we've approved today
and those that i know that are in the
pipeline which will be coming through
the council meetings that we're going to
attend to in the near future so
consequently i would i would plead with
the case officers to make certain that
they take note of your concerns and that
we try and make certain that we can
rebuild the confidence of the kinds and
community in the work dealing with the
applications that come within that
parish did you have a second question
council mills yes I do actually thank
you
thank you Miss Jenna leader yes on the
on that last application that came for
committee it was just it was decided by
the chairman that approximate n and what
would if either posed a poll here
what would you say approximately ten
maybe nine or eleven and approximately
ten came to fourteen I just wondered
what your views were on approximately
ten is it nine eleven or fourteen Thank
You chairman I think the straightforward
answer is approximately ten does not
equate to fourteen right I would perhaps
give the developers the benefit of the
doubt and perhaps include eleven rather
than nine in the assessment it is not
going to be ten Thank You councillor
kettles Sharon I'm sure the leaders
aware that many affordable housing
tenants have received notice this month
of the prepared to production of a new
level of charges for what might be
called garden maintenance these charges
in my ward alone seem to vary between
about a hundred pounds per tenant per
month in some properties and up to 400
pounds per tenant in other properties I
know that we have no commercial
relationship with orbit but there has
been a serious level of concern among
tenants both in my ward and I'm
understanding from other tenants from
other counsel sorry that they've had
similar correspondence will the District
Council be making any representations to
them housing station association to
ensure if they continue with this
proposal to introduce charges that there
is absolute clarification on what
services are being included in that
charge and that it is totally justified
and they're not just using this as an
opportunity to raise additional funds
for their association which is the
belief among quite a few times
the moment chairman a positive part of
the answer and perhaps in a different
part the issue is that through our work
on the strategic review which was
approved by the council this October
meeting we have effectively improved and
enhanced our relationships with certain
external stakeholders and all
warehousing it's one of those so we will
be meeting with them on various
occasions and indeed I think the issue
would be appropriate for me to take up
councillor kettles issue over the
supplementary charges with the
principles of orbit when we do get round
to the table with them do you have a
second question no other questions no
that's great so we finished ahead of
time I've actually no no on the
questions we have you were allowed 30
minutes from 1532 hours within that
space of time so 18 nursin of motions
update that's for information only you
can see the detail there which you can
always refer to now we have two motions
of notice in item 19 would councillor
Mawson councillor freshly like to
necessary or refer them to cabinet the
second fine
so we'll refer that to cabinet and the
other one is about child centers cancer
for tech and personal bonds formally
how's it do we have any urgent business
under Section people won't see it there
in your agenda no I'll just let me wish
you all a peaceful Chris
and a Happy New Year and invite you for
including you mr. Gosling at this time
for a small glass of wine and some mince
pies which